most men only around 20 percent of men  can really sleep around like that and  then so then it comes back to the women  because who are we picking to sleep with  yeah because also most people  if I took if I know most guys I know  they like to sleep without I feel like  most people let's be honest like to  sleep without condoms right but at the  end of the day  let's say you meet a guy on a party and  you choose to sleep without a condom  yeah you don't know what he's been doing  he might have been in London Birmingham  Rio de Janeiro Paris Amsterdam he's been  everywhere and you let him enter that's  not only about you let him maybe getting  pregnant that's about you being  irresponsible with your body and I feel  like a lot of people need to come to  terms with themselves and think you know  what this is my body